three time interceptions leader one of
the best of the best
I'd read back here on the show how you
been head where do we find you this time
room now where are you know yeah I'm in
Georgia okay what are you doing in
Georgia just being just living yeah I
would say that but I'm Nam and I'm mom
as you find me I'm doing a toy drive
here in Georgia with a few cigar bars
I've been teamed up with those so
community work down here in Georgia and
when you know just try to work with some
underprivileged kids and you know
support some people during Christmastime
who are less fortunate
yeah I know I know you've got the Eddie
Reed's foundation and there's a lot
going on there I definitely want to hit
you on that but well I've got you
driving around what type of cigar do you
like it do you smoke cigars yourself I
do okay you know I've been I've been
trying a whole bunch of different ones
right now the camera the camera in the
maduro you know so okay I've been I'm
researching right now rich because I'm
trying to make my own cigar you know
I've been I've been smoking some will
leave us some Padron's okay you know so
it's been good man this process does
your phone do that every time you say
the word padrone does it is that is that
trained to do okay very good here on the
show what do you think of the Ravens
chances of winning this year ad getting
to the to the playoffs and making a run
here what do you say oh my thing they
made it tough obviously the last game
was a big one I thought no you don't
double a be it to begin the game but any
part of the game but I'm it was a great
game I think those guys are playing
playing pretty decent football right now
I don't know about um what I'm talking
about he's from the U but anyway what do
you mean but those guys they were
looking decent man you know I got to see
how to the end of this shakeout because
they have a very favorable next couple
games but you know never know how to
you gotta you gotta finish it you got to
finish them game strong you know just
like the last one without you know if
you finish it the right way you know you
come out on top without one in
Pittsburgh
I guess Weddell was pointing out that
Utah is out of you at the front of it
way before there was a University of
Miami I think that's what he you mm-hmm
you had a problem with that I'm sure how
do you think Antonio Brown keeps doing
it ed
everybody knows he's getting a boat and
I've been watching it week after week
why wasn't the safety lean that way he's
the number one he's the best receiver in
the NFL right now he's getting 10 plus
catches he had nine at that point why
wouldn't you lean towards him if you
lean towards a be any safety in the NFL
would get a interception a week he's
going to get the ball it's not what you
would do rich if you go back to the AFC
Championship in Pittsburgh they threw
that same pass they've been trying to
pass for years on that same sideline to
a B and ain't nobody stopping it it's
crazy so we played him up there same
pass he crushed us on he first got into
the NFL why are they not doubling him I
don't know these are great questions B
I'm imagining the Patriots will do that
this week what do you think's got the
edge in that game right now I'm looking
like Pittsburgh but it might be pretty
evening because you know it's mean you
don't you don't see New England having
two really bad games back to back foot
and that's that defense of Pittsburgh is
a little shaky right now with Ryan we
praying for um is you know not in the
middle of that defense right now so
those guys got to step up and I'm sure
after playing last week you know they
will because Pittsburgh usually make
pretty decent adjustments going forward
as well well over the years ed Reed that
Tom Brady has been Tom Brady and that's
been pretty much every minute of his
entire professional playing existence
the Ravens seem to have had the most
success
defensively certainly going into
Gillette what were you able to do
against Brady that is so difficult for
others to replicate yeah reason I hate
to speaking therapist okay good we want
somebody who's looking for every snap
you know so that causes up cause a
little confusion for the Pacers when you
had to worry about a certain person out
there but now man we had pass rushers we
had every level of defense and everybody
was on one Accord and that's what you
have to be playing against somebody like
Brady just meticulous you know with that
bald man on what he you know the people
he's getting it to the the speed of the
offensive high blue high flows you know
those seem to be doing things that we
that they've done when when I was in the
league you know on the hurry of Baltar's
don't seem to be as fast as it used to
be ed Reed joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show okay what'd you think of the
suspensions the one game for Gronk and
then the one game for juju Smiths
Shuster but the one game for George
Iloka lifted from two weeks ago dad I
think gross should have been worse you
can tell that that that he was trying to
do that you there's no doubt about it
that he was trying to do that he had a
morning of time to think about dropping
the WWE elbow down on the guy and I mean
Juju's standing over the guy you got to
get it to for that you know I mean this
game this game has come pretty far and
you already know how Pittsburgh and
Cincinnati rivalry has been I'm sure
that God was in college watching that
robbery at Heinz Laura you know really
started that with breaking that guy's
jaw from Cincinnati that riot that that
the game has been crazy since then
between Cincinnati and Pittsburgh maybe
need somebody to go counsel both teams
when it comes that week because it
it's really out of hand on how those to
act against each other you know that's
not a robbery that's more like a brawl
you know so I think something needs to
be talked about with Cincinnati and
Pittsburgh and also just those militias
is that grunt you know himself has done
you know it's a brotherhood
man and those guys need to understand
that you know you can play super hard
you can still hit people hard but at the
end of the day should take care of each
other you know kind of like playing
basketball before all-star break you
know it's interesting it because that
was part of the conversation nationally
after that monday night football game is
that the league is pretty much done all
it can do and they might even bring
targeting into the NFL now and and then
the officials are out there with so much
on their hands in terms of split-second
decisions on intent and and down a
distance right and you can have more
referees there's nothing wrong with
refereeing the game from cameras there's
no different than watching society from
cameras like they do in London
I mean it can be done you know so so
we're watching it on TV saying that's a
bullcrap hit and we're talking about it
today so they can't put us in our office
and watch the game incident or add more
um referees to the game I mean that
stage that could be done I'm watching
I'm watching the technology that they
have in tennis to see if the ball is in
or out you mean attend me we can't do
certain thing we can do it we don't want
to do it yet but we don't want to spend
the money you know we got billions to do
it to police our game to make it better
you know we don't do those things well
but why do you think it's so difficult
for players to police themselves then in
the manner that you're saying that they
should that that's a great question but
it's also the same thing about society
you know how people cheat - how people
act no people only have so much capacity
in their thinking to get past certain
things you know you're talking about
situations and circumstances you're
talking about guys who are bumping their
head constantly during the game you know
you got you're talking about guys who
are training to react constantly you
know in offseason and then when they get
in season you're telling them not to
react not to not to hit a guy not to
pull up that's frustrating that's a lot
to think about you know so the NFL need
to think about how they're implementing
the rules - versus the mentality that
these guys are training in you know in
offseason in the offseason we trained to
react I mean you want us to untrain that
when we get to the season that's going
to cost us what you see right now all
right and before I let you go here let's
talk about your foundation your you
acquired land in your neighborhood of
st. Charles Parish right and you're
planning on this lady donated it for
like a hundred years mmm like awesome -
like a dollar and that was pretty much
the only land outside of some other
property that you know got a bunch of
families connected to it we can't get to
where I rather put it but we just can't
get to it but uh she donated it and we
bought the book we're gonna put a
parking you know in my neighborhood
because I mean that's where it's needed
you know I grew up at the park I saw the
great football you saw over the years
came from the park I'm a park baby you
know as I tell people you know and and
we're doing some stuff up in Baltimore
of course you might have heard of it
Glenn Dottie um had a recreation center
called shake and bake in Baltimore and
it just needs some some refurbishing you
know right in the neighborhood where
they had the riots right by Booker T
Washington where we um work with that
school that needs a lot of help as well
you know so we're still moving rich got
to keep moving man got to keep helping
the community
also such situations you know what's
going on with your in life you know you
you get knocked down you keep getting
back up is no different than football
you know still still moving that way and
stink this you know that's why I'm
messing with these cigars and trying to
try to get with the right people to put
out you know three cigars you know a
full body a medium body and a cigar for
the ladies you are the man at 20 ER on
Twitter at Reid foundation.org / donate
to get part of what you're doing I'd
love you had read I don't care who knows
it
you're the best right back at you well
chat soon that's ed Reid have a great
Christmas and holiday season the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience